Next question today.
Hey David, should teachers be allowed to discuss
politics in the classroom?
Why or why not?
Um, so first of all, we've got to understand
that there's a kind of practical element to
the question of politics in the classroom.
And then there's also a question of taboo.
So when we talk about whether your dentists
should discuss politics, it's a different
conversation than whether teachers should
discuss politics.
And discuss is also different from advocate
for or lobby, right?
When your dentists discuss his politics, it's
really just a risk to them because if you
don't agree with their politics or you don't
like the fact that they're talking about politics,
you can just go to another dentist assuming
that there's a sort of market of dentists
that are reasonably priced and accessible
in your area.
Um, when teachers talk about politics, it's
different because of the idea in society that
teachers are in a position of authority when
it comes to knowledge.
And we presumably, I think most parents don't
want teachers biasing our children, particularly
if they're biasing our children in ways that
are not in line with our personal politics
because the children may not be able to differentiate
from just like normal classroom material and
the teacher advocating politics.
This is why advertising to children is actually
so pernicious.
There's a period of time when children don't
understand the difference between just fun
programming and something that's trying to
get you to buy a product.
And that's why advertising kids is pernicious.
And presumably the same thing could happen
when teachers mix classroom material with
politics.
I do think that if we're going to talk about
the seriously, it's gotta be divided between
sort of like elementary school, Middle School,
high school starts to become a gray area and
college.
I truly couldn't tell you the politics of
almost any of my elementary school teachers.
And I do think that sticking to the curriculum
in a way that's not overtly political does
make sense in American public schools.
But in a lot of classes we just don't need
politics in math class for example, there
are areas though, once you get into science,
once you get into human geography, there are
political realities that are either implicit
or unavoidable in those areas.
And I still think in those cases teachers
should be able to keep the advocacy to a minimum.
Don't advocate necessarily for particular
candidates, for example.
But in science class you've got to talk about
the environment.
How do you not talk about climate change?
Uh, I don't believe climate change is political.
It's just the reality.
But there are people who do, but teachers
have to be able to talk about that.
It's just the world around us that they're
describing in college.
It gets different, I think, but more call,
more, more college politics in the classroom
is okay, uh, advocating for or against specific
candidates.
Maybe it should be kept out of the classroom,
but we're talking about adults.
We're talking about people who are better
able to identify what's a personal view, what
is coursework?
Um, there's no question that the underlying
philosophy and subject matter and a lot of
college classes is inherently political and
pretending that it can just be kept out is
not reasonable.
And you're actually starting to do damage
to students if you artificially keep politics
out.
So as with most things, the answer is it depends.
It depends what we're talking about.
It depends what age we're talking about, but
some political realities in the classroom
or not only unavoidable, they should be, uh,
uh, advisable.
They're actually advisable so that people,
students have a realistic understanding of
what is going on in the world.